able to lead a government
that can command the confidence of the
House of Representatives
I now ask you to confirm that you can
lead such a government
in that case I will proceed with your
appointment as prime minister
your Excellency the letters patent
constituting the office of governor
general of New Zealand authorize and
Empower you to appoint Ministers of the
crown
I submit for your signature a warrant
appointing The Honorable Chris Atkins as
prime minister
that gives effect to your appointment as
prime minister congratulations prime
minister Evans
foreign
the next part of the ceremony involves
the appointment of the Deputy Prime
Minister and one other portfolio
appointment these appointments are made
on the advice of the Prime Minister
foreign
your Excellency is advised on the
recommendation of the Prime Minister to
make two appointments to ministerial
office
the right honorable Chris Hipkins
Minister for National Security and
intelligence
The Honorable Carmel cipolloni Deputy
Prime Minister
foreign
your Excellency that completes today's
appointments
prime minister
Deputy Prime Minister
my warmest congratulations to you both
I also want to acknowledge and
congratulate all of your families
and your supporters who are here today
it has been my pleasure to welcome you
all to government house
for this very special occasion
I know that our new prime minister and
Deputy Prime Minister will rely on your
support in order to fulfill their roles
for the good of new zealanders
the right honorable Chris Hipkins
I very much look forward to working with
you
I have come to both cherish and
appreciate the importance of the
relationship between the Prime Minister
and the governor general
a relationship integral to New Zealand's
constitutional Arrangements
as prime minister
you are my principal ministerial advisor
a role that will look take on particular
importance this election year
I look forward to our meetings together
and to your updates on the business of
government as New Zealand continues to
face challenges on both the domestic and
the international stage
prime minister
Deputy Prime Minister my congratulations
to you both once again
and I hope that you take this moment to
reflect and celebrate with your loved
ones and I wish you both the very best
with your new roles
your Excellency thank you for your kind
words and for hosting the appointment
ceremony here at government house today
as I've said before this is the biggest
privilege and responsibility of my life
I'm energized and excited by the
challenges that liar hit
the Deputy Prime Minister and I both
take today's appointments very seriously
as prime minister I acknowledge the
important nature of my role in advising
The Sovereign and the governor general
I express my personal thanks to you and
look forward to working with you
your Excellency thank you for your kind
words
prime minister congratulations on your
well-deserved appointment
and thank you for the trust that you
have placed in me I thank you for
honoring me my family and our Pacific
Community through this appointment
I look forward to working with you and
supporting you in this very important
role
ceremony for the appointment of the new
prime minister and Deputy Prime Minister
would everybody please stand
thank you
foreign
I'd like to invite you to make your way
through the blundle room for
Refreshments through these doors here
the governor general prime minister and
the Deputy Prime Minister will join you
shortly
[Applause]
thank you